PIETRO MAGGI: With
Android Vitals,
you identify performance
issues in your app.
Android Vitals
provide information
about battery use, stability,
rendering, app startup time,
and permission request.
In this DevBytes,
I'm going to show you
how to address the
battery-related issues
of stuck partial wake locks
and excessive wakeups.
With the WakeLocks
API, you keep a device
from entering the
sleep, and as a result,
prevent it from
conserving the battery.
A stuck wake lock occurs
when you acquire a wake lock
but never release it.
So the device keeps the CPU
running and drains the battery.
What's the best way to avoid
stuck partial wake locks?
Simple solution is to
stop to using them.
In modern Android,
there is rarely
the situation where you
have to use a wake lock.
For example, take an activity.
Whenever someone
is using your app
and you want to keep the screen
on, instead of setting a wake
lock, use a flag on the window
that will tell the system
to keep the screen on.
As a bonus, there is no
way to lift the flag.
For services, if
you schedule them
as job instead of using
custom free running services,
the job scheduler also
release the wake lock for you.
Similarly, if you use the
AlarmManager to schedule
an alarm in
BroadcastReceiver, there
will be a wake lock for you for
the duration of the on.Receive.
If you don't use wake
locks, another benefit
is that you don't need
to include the permission
request in your manifest.
But if you must use a wake lock,
always use a partial wake lock.
[? Data ?] types of wake
locks are deprecated
in the latest version Android.
Always set a timeout
value in wakeLock.acquire
so that the system
waking up the wake
lock after the timeout expires.
Also give your wake lock
a static, descriptive tag
without counters, or even
worse, private or sensitive
information.
Why?
Because Android Vitals
will report on the wake
lock by name, making it easier
for you to debug issues.
Finally, remember
to code defensively.
Assume that things
can go wrong and use
"try" and "finally"
blocks to make sure
that you released wake locks as
soon as you are done with them.
The second half of the Android
Vitals battery equation
is excessive wakeups.
The main contributor
to excessive wakeups
is their use of the
older AlarmManager API.
Specifically, the
WAKEUP type of alarms.
When working with
AlarmManager, there
are three Rs that
you should consider.
Remove codes to wakeup
alarms, if possible,
reduce the frequency if you
have to use a wakeup alarms,
and replace your
alarm with other APIs.
When it comes to
replacing, if they wakeup
is for something
happening on your server,
send it as a push message
using Firebase Cloud Messaging.
For activity triggering
on the device,
use one of the job scheduling
API, such a WorkManager,
JobScheduler, or SyncManager.
This intelligent job
scheduling mechanism
gives you a lot for free,
such as the automatic backoff
and retry if your job
fails for any reason,
criteria-based scheduling,
so you can wake up
the device only when it
has a network connection
or is charging, doze
and standby compliance,
and automatic wake
lock handling.
Regardless of whether
Android Vitals is telling you
there is a battery problem
in your app or not,
remember to use Android
Studio and [INAUDIBLE]
for [INAUDIBLE].
With this tool, you can debug
any kind of wake lock problems
and get details about alarms
and JobScheduler in your app.
People will quickly
remove our app
if they encounter battery
problems after installing it.
Following the guidelines
in this video,
you should be able to
avoid battery programs
in the first place.
But if you don't, Android Vitals
will quickly identify for you.
To find out more about
Android Vitals and the ways
of addressing battery
problems, check the resources
listed in the video description.
Remember, to find out about
this and other feature
in the Play Console and get
tips to grow your app or games
business, you can
use the Playbook app
available on Google Play.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]